the next morning when the lights went on
in this hearing room in front of dozens
of senators and hundreds of people
actually in the audience
i said you know senators i know i'm here
to appear before you as the head of a
u.s regulatory agency but if you don't
mind for a second i just want to talk to
you as a dad
and i explained that i had three kids
then then in their early 20s who were
where i tried to interest in the stock
market you know throughout their teenage
years with no effect but all they wanted
to talk about now is crypto and the same
with my nieces and nephews and i said
you know senators i think
we owe it to this generation to respond
to this
interest not with derision and and and
you know
uh disrespect but with with real
intelligence i think we owe it to get
this regulation right to respond to this
uh this new innovation and quite frankly
this generational interest in it
with with a forward-leaning thoughtful
response
and as i just had gotten those words out
of my mouth
my twitter feed just exploded i think i
had a thousand followers when i went to
the hearing and within you know 72 hours
i think i had 46 45 000 twitter
followers but you know it was just and
that's where the name crypto dad came
from some folks came up with lots of
good memes uh crypto dad was the one
that seemed to stick
because i said i'm here as a dad but the
real point of it was
it was clear to me in 2015 2017 that
this is much more than just some new fad
asset class
this is really a fundamental
re-architecting of financial services of
banking and most importantly money
itself hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time